brothers and sisters welcome
back to the realest podcast in the dunya
we are actually here together
alhamdulillah we got the studio popping
we got this beautiful sign right here if
you can see it you can see it you know
what it is you know what it do you know
what it'd be
so we are here today and we want to talk
about
we want to talk about boys the
difference between being a good man
and being good at being a man yeah what
does that even mean bro yeah let me
define that we spoke about it a little
bit right you spoke about it maybe a few
hours ago yeah it found a lot of
difference it's kind of like the
difference between a nice guy and a good
guy right i don't want to confuse the
term so a good guy is someone who like
they look like they're a good guy right
they they act like a good guy they're
nice
i think that's a nice guy that's a nice
guy okay but we're using the term good
guy here sure sure
i mean usually the nice guy versus a guy
a good guy someone with good morality
he's a good man so on and so forth a
nice guy someone who's nice because he
has to be nice right it's also like
being harmless it's fake yeah it's
almost like being harmless
versus being peaceful right it's
something you used to talk about a lot
you could be harmless meaning you can't
cause harm at all or you can be peaceful
meaning you can cause harm you choose
not to i think that's a very key
difference but go going to inshallah bro
i wanted to touch on one point that you
said jordan peterson talked about this
in an episode um or like a lecture
because he used to be a prof you know
before the woke mob got him kicked out
of ufc
um may allah make it easy for him but
basically u of t he was a prophet u of t
i thought i said ufc i'm like that no no
no no no no
no but basically what he said was
a good man or a virtuous man is not just
you know a nice guy who's not capable of
violence he said a good man is a man
that's very capable of violence but he
chooses to turn that switch off and use
it when necessary meaning that if
someone's let's say never had money you
can't say that they're or let's say
they're always broke right you can't say
that this person is really good at you
know financially savvy because they
never had the fitness of having the
money
but if they have money and they choose
to spend it wisely and in the in the
with the nia of keeping allah in mind
then you could say they're financially
savvy so similarly a good man according
to him is not a a weak man
or a man that's soft it's a very strong
man a very dangerous man capable of
literally you know violence and then
defending others but uses it when
necessary so similarly bro i want you
all to understand that there's a
difference between a good man and one
who's just good at being a man right a
good man is just someone that wants to
appear good you know always agreeable
always just going with the crowd never
likes to make decisions and and be a
good leader but one who's good at being
a man knows that there's responsibility
there's accountability first and
foremost by allah
and also makes decisions based on what's
right not just what is likable you know
and they're good leaders and so on and
so forth bro yeah 100 bro when someone
says and you mentioned this before right
a man who's good at being a man who's
the first man that comes to mind other
than the prophet ali
of course
right what about you
i don't know man i'm a little lost
well let me let me break it down for you
in simple terms oh no i know what it is
i'm just
let me still bring you some thinking
about the popcorn that's true guys you
guys listening you're depriving me of my
popcorn and and
yes depriving
me of his eyes okay my ice cap yeah
listen guys we're gonna give you an
inside scoop only because this is the
first episode so we'll do this as satya
kajalia but basically what happened was
you guys have no idea what went down
just to get this episode like popping
i'm i'm not even making this up like
we had probably four to five hours going
just to get this recorded we were
supposed to start last week uh rami
spilled his ice cap you know in the
process
deprived of his popcorn bro like insha
allah if you all don't smash this like
button and share this with all of your
friends then we're quitting youtube bro
at this rate like we need your support
bismillah
but essentially
when you think of a good man who's not
good at being a man think of like that
hollywood uh netflix homer simpson type
father that's portrayed in the media bro
the one that just is a yes man you know
he's a good man because he's still nice
and he puts the feelings of others upon
above what is right
but one who's good at being a man
might not be good as a man he might be
evil but he gets the job done he knows
what he wants he believes what he wants
is always right and he always takes the
right path never the easy path
so when you were talking about brother
gabriel romani masha'allah um he's a man
that comes to mind because he's a good
man obviously because he's not an evil
man he's a good man he wants the best
for his brothers and sisters and and you
know he's virtuous but he's also good at
being a man masha'allah gabriel if
you're watching this bro
mashallah but
he's capable he's strong he takes care
of his family takes care of his kids you
know he defends those that are oppressed
he always stands up for the truth for
right that's what someone who's good at
being a man
yeah
100
you are in the sign
look at that
you mentioned something i think i i want
to clarify a little bit right you said a
person
who's not a good man but good at being a
man right and you said that this
person's always on the right path just
want to clarify you what you mean is
what they think is the right path
what they see as truth not the easy path
yeah 100
and i think obviously you know as
muslims this is where islam ties in
because you know what is the right path
what is
good what is you know evil what is you
know we watch a lot of andrew t clips
and how islam is the last stronghold and
all this stuff he's not a muslim a lot
of what he says obviously he's confused
a little bit about him or maybe
overemphasized certain things more than
it needs to be overemphasized
um but nonetheless i'd say he falls into
that category of a man who's good at
being a man 100
whether he's a good man or not we can't
confirm or deny that right because it's
only up to allah to judge but based on
at least my personal standards i would
say a good man is a man who's on deen
who puts you know the rights of allah
first and looks after his brothers and
sisters in islam that's a good man
but
unfortunately today in society we have
too many men that are good at being men
but they're not good men you know think
of like villains super villains in like
movies they're good at being men because
they put what they think is right above
anything else they put their life on the
line for that you know what i mean
but there's also men that are good men
but they're not good at being men these
are men that they want to be agreeable
they want to just kind of be a yes man
put everyone's needs above their own
um which is a good thing by the way
right we should care about everyone else
but not when it comes to
truth and falsehood
life and death and standing up for those
that are oppressed bro yeah
so what do you think is the solution bro
for this epidemic islam
well because if you look at all the
sahaba
they were good men that were good at
being men
for real
of course i mean i'm sure i know that
but a lot of people don't and and when
you when you think of the deen a lot of
people subhanallah they think islam is
just about being a good man
but let me rephrase that right i said
islam
but it should better be said
um practicing
islam there's like a lot of
actually
i don't even know if i'm i should be
saying this but there are a lot of
people out here
who they say they're muslim but they
don't really
you know they're just muslim by by word
by mouth yeah but by heart there's
something else it's kind of like what
you were saying before i like
well we're gonna be brought up on the
day of judgment you're gonna be asked
who is your lord who's your prophet
and what is your deen
what is your your religion your way of
life and it's not you it's not it's not
your logic
but it's the heart
the heart is going to reply so imagine
you have people who they say they're
muslim they say they follow islam
but in their heart is something
different
you know so now let's say you had
someone who in their heart um they're a
true muslim
they're actually following islam like
this makes you
a good man
and it makes you good at being a man why
because the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam has set the perfect example and
not only him
but all the other sahabah
are they
that are documented
you know
yeah
100 man 100
subhanallah and um
islam is not just you know our standard
or his standard or her standard islam is
the standard right if you talk about one
objective standard what is true right
how you should be
right and this
digs into morality obviously is
objective subjective blah blah all that
stuff but if you believe there is a way
people ought to behave in terms of
morality then it must be objective to
you and if it is objective you can only
get that from god there's basically no
other way to get it you can try you can
argue you won't get anywhere so you'll
go through life like basically trying
this trying that thinking this thinking
that never being able to prove what's
right or wrong or whatever just
thinking about it making these
analogies all the time they make a lot
of analogies for pro life or
pro-abortion and all this different
stuff yeah it's honestly it's useless i
think it's useless just submit to god
allah has sent you away allah sent you
the way of life and on top of that a
prophet
who lived it so we can actually
have the the more practical the wisdom
behind it as well as the prophet lived
his life and allah says that in the
quran he sent the quran the book and the
wisdom of the prophet so it's very
clearly laid out for us so you know
it's sad as the brother mentioned
that we have people right who say
they're muslim don't act like they're
muslim subhanallah there are a lot of
people and it's it's more so in my
opinion sad when i see men acting this
way who will literally put the crowd
before allah
they we watched what did we watch
recently the true story by kevin hart
right
bro
this whole thing started why because not
because he put something before god
necessarily but because he put peer
pressure what his friends thought what
his brother trying to push him to over
what he thinks is right exactly
man see ro
when we when we talk about a lot of you
know the red pill community all that
these are men that they've they've
understood you know female psychology
they understood how human nature works
and they deem what they think is success
they're getting you know they're getting
the money they're getting fame they're
getting what they think will bring their
happiness their go-getters in a way so
in a way they're good at being men but
they're not good men because there's no
morality there there's no islam that
like brother rami was saying so there's
not much in terms of you know objective
morality and virtuosity and all that
type of stuff you know they they can
yeah bet 10 women and they can make 10
racks a month and they can do all this
stuff but they're not good men
and i don't want you guys to think you
know we should go to the other extreme
either where it's like you know being a
good man is everything you know you
don't have to actually work hard and
work on your physique and make money and
make a provisioning and all that too
so on bro i got a question for you first
and foremost before we go on to rami but
how do you find the balance between both
because there's i don't want to talk
about you know which specific type of
muslim you know because we're not out
here to divide sex and all that but
they're the types of muslims today that
are out here saying
all that matters is the spirituality you
know the physical body doesn't matter
dunya doesn't matter you know it's all
about
but then you also have muslims that are
here like you know they don't pray
necessarily you know but they're they're
go-getters they're like you know i work
out every day i meditate every day i
want to be a good i want to be good at
being a man per se
excuse me how i find the balance how you
approach life trying to strike that
balance bro between the two
ana's going to let us know when he finds
out
yeah i'm still trying to figure that out
um
that's like um
that's like a everyday type thing you're
trying to figure it out the um striking
the balance my balance and i was saying
how like it's an everyday type thing i'm
still trying to figure it out i think
we're all trying to figure it out
you know but i was saying like you said
not to get too caught up in a dunya but
not to get too caught up in a here like
finding the middle path
you know like the the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he said there's a time
and place for everything like when the
sahaba they were reflecting on jannah
and jahannam
and they were reflecting on it so much
that it's like to them it seemed like it
was real they could see it
and then when they went home and they
were with their family
they were just laughing and it's as if
they forgot everything they felt like
hypocrites so they went to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and they're
like like
we feel like hypocrites like what do we
do
what do you say there's a time and place
for everything so i feel like that
middle path is very important
and um
again you need to have both you need to
have the constant practice of like
okay well what am i doing here
like what is my actual purpose am i
fulfilling my purpose here as a muslim
you know am i doing things for the sake
of allah
or am i doing things for my own sake um
you know and then
um you got to take care of the body that
that allah has given you you got to take
care of the skills that you have and all
that stuff right
so i was like if you don't take care of
these both aspects well then one is
going to suffer or multiple is going to
suffer
and um
yeah that's the best answer that we're
going to give
but what bothers me so much is when i go
to the masjid and may allah bless all
these brothers that i'm about to talk
about but there's so many men that i see
today
they have you know their habit of the
quran you know they're showing up to the
masjid for fajr mashallah but they're
like 400 pounds bro or they don't know
how to fight
or i see them you know going out with
their wife and i literally see people
pulling up on them and disrespecting
them and they don't do anything and at
the end of the day we can't have this
false pious type of mentality that oh
just being good means everything you
know that's what islam is about no islam
is not about that bro
that the youth will never enter jannah
bro and and those that are weak and and
let people get oppressed and don't fight
in in the cause of allah
what do you think is going to happen let
me let me stop there for a second
because for a while i used to think the
same thing and used to i really used to
see people that didn't want to learn how
to like let's say defend themselves and
people with i used to see them as like
useless
i really had to think about this and
take a step back and realize look
allah has made us good at different
things
now as long as they're making the effort
or they have the
nia intention i think that's all that
matters
but
i would have to say i disagree to some
extent i agree in principle but i think
as men we should strive the perfect
balance and and we're human bro we can't
be perfect but we should try to do both
you know we look at the models that
allah has given us like the prophet saw
and these are not you know models like
superhero from comics you know or
willy-nilly uh you know people we look
at in the dunya today no these are the
models that we have to follow as muslims
and when you look at that they were
never one or the other
you know you look at
like when you look at him bro he he
where did his name come from bro
was he the son of bakker no
what did what did abu bakr mean bro
bakker mean i believe it meant strength
you know like he was the son of strength
and someone could correct me from wrong
but that's where he got that name from a
lot of these these these sahaba bro they
were they were feared even look at imam
mohammed bro i was speaking to a brother
today where they were talking about you
know there was a girl who was uh
possessed by a jinn you know and uh one
of the students of imam mahmud ramallah
came to him said there's a girl
possessed by jinn what should we do
and imam muhammad gave the student his
sandal his slipper right
and basically said you know go use this
on the jin so basically the student went
to the girl who was possessed
started talking to the jinn and
basically said you know this is the
slipper of uh imam ahmed rahim allah i'm
going to hit you with this and bro the
gin literally left
they didn't even think twice the
generally said i'm like they're scared
bro they just left
and uh
same thing happened again after imam
ahmed rahim allah passed away um the
same same girl got possessed
you know she did the same thing i
believe they did the same thing they
took the sandal came back right and
wanted to you know strike and this time
the jin didn't go away
because he's like you fool i don't i
don't fear you but i fear imam ahmed
and look um
the way he walked shaytan took the other
route you told me this
so these were these were men that really
did know how to be good men at the end
of the day
and yes there are definitely some
brothers with metabolic conditions that
can't work out and all this what about
ism so we're not we're not making this
one-size-fits-all type of thing
but in general i believe all of us
should be doing something about trying
to become good men
and also being good at being men
and i think balance is ki bro islam is
the middle path yeah i mean if you look
at the the hadith of the prophet they
saw them to kind of tie in what both you
were saying well i love sharing this
it's so beautiful it's it's like a
formula for life essentially right um
and if someone were to ask me you know
how should i live life i would just call
the hadith process them where he said
the strong believer is better and more
beloved to allah than the weak believer
all right strength isn't just physical
it could be mental it can be
psychological it could be
financial right it could be in wrestling
and grappling and striking many
different things right strong believer
is better and more beloved to allah than
the weak believer but there is hair in
everyone there is good in everyone and
it continues people usually quote that
and stop or they quote the last bit and
the stop but it's one whole hadith so
what does he say after that
it kind of begs the question okay how do
i get strong right i want to be strong
how do i get strong the process of me
answers that
he says hold on tightly to what benefits
you and do not lose your heart don't
don't become hopeless right anything
that gives you benefit if someone offers
you free classes to train that gives you
benefit take it right someone offers you
ten thousand dollars to start a business
bro take it it benefits you take it hold
on tightly to what benefits you and do
not lose your heart don't become
hopeless that begs the question what
would make a person hopeless and he
answers that as well
he says if anything comes to you in the
form of a calamity of something
difficult
well that's beautiful he says don't say
if don't say man if only i invested the
ten thousand here instead of there then
this would have happened i said i would
have tripled my money right we see this
all the time bro oh my god i visited in
this stock this crypto this little and
it went down this one went up
subhanallah i should have listened to
fulan blah blah whatever right he said
don't say if
he says rather say
it's the destiny the career of allah and
allah does as he wills he says because
if opens the door to shaytaan and that's
exactly how we should live life and
another summary i would give
is
honestly just have allah is your
priority
right you you know allah has certain
roles responsibilities regulations for
you as a man in life
just look at what allah wants you know
you know you live in in perhaps an area
in the west where maybe islamophobia is
rising
you know you have women you have to
protect you know that allah wants you to
be strong courageous and brave and able
to protect your women okay that's one
thing you have to do that's one
responsibility allah says you have to
provide for your family have a source of
income you know that's on the table you
know obviously you have to pray after
fasting have to give us a cat so on and
so forth you know these things just make
allah priority don't make training mma
your priority you're a losing you're a
loser if you do that make allah your
priority and then everything else will
fall in line by extension wallahi i was
going to say the exact same thing that
you just said bro when you make allah
your priority look at the five pillars
of islam yeah they're all to make you
good men but also make you good of being
a man and i want to give some praise
masha'allah to this brother angel over
here and just seeing all the progress
he's made with mma and martial arts the
last couple years and it really goes to
show me bro the stuff that's happening
in india bro all the women that are you
know getting their hijabs pulled off
getting assaulted in public getting
harassed bro where are the men do they
know how to fight and it begs the
question we had shaykh with monument on
the podcast and he was saying
had the men been there we still wouldn't
have known if they would have stepped up
or not we wouldn't have known bro
and and and what's sad then and always
says it's better to have something and
not need it than to need it and not have
it right so it's better to know how to
fight and to know how to be a dangerous
man capable of protecting those around
him even if you don't have to equip it
every single day you don't need to grow
and this
comes back
where
there's a base
there's a base
that makes us
good men and it makes us good at being
men
right
so
you look at your environment you look
where you're at you look at what needs
your attention the most
like do you actually need to defend
yourself do you need to defend the
people you're with is that a main
priority right now in the environment
that you're in maybe you live in a
dangerous area maybe this is something
you need to know okay tell us that's one
thing on the table that you need to put
attention to um
hey maybe you have a condition maybe
you're physically not in the best shape
possible that's
all right
there's ways around this
right like maybe you can't use your
hands
but you could use something else
you know
and um i'm trying i want to do the
motion here but i feel like so
constricted
so
it's like this you know and holding
something like that yeah you get it
right so there's there's different ways
around this right you you want to learn
how to defend yourself and the people
you're with
there's multiple ways to go about doing
this i think that's going to get us
de-platformed bro no bro it's
i could have been holding up a paintball
yeah he's holding up a paintball uh gun
youtube community guidelines get your
head out the gutter bro yeah so
basically listen what i'm trying to say
is that um
and i don't think we're in disagreement
neither of us i think we're all in
agreement i think we all understand that
there's a base but then we all
understand that
um there are specialties within that so
it's like if you have an army not
everyone in the army is going to be the
same
they're not all going to be front line
you're gonna have some people that are
arrangers that are
they're chilling they're up
they're in the back but they're sniping
you know like they're
they're watching the entire field right
then you have some people who are
frontline then you have some people who
aren't but they're like further back and
they're like heavy utility or something
like that right so everyone has a
different thing but they all guaranteed
have the base
you know what i'm saying like and then
this is the base that we should outline
in today's podcast this is something
that we should leave
these brothers and these sisters that
are watching these sisters you know if
you want to
tell your brothers or your family
members
but um
let's outline that what do you all think
is the base
right now for a proper man to balance to
be a good man and to be
good at being a man
around me bro
when you say base are you looking for
bare minimum something general or
something the
the whole the whole thing we're talking
about is
being a good man and being good at being
a man
encompassing the whole thing now we
understand that encompassing the whole
thing is gonna
it's gonna derive from a base
i see i see so i mean it's gonna be hard
because listing out attributes you're go
you're going to miss a few right so
that's why even again i would say just
have the quran because
she said that the prophet saw his
character was the quran you find all
over the quran allah he says speak the
truth even if it's against yourself
right
there many a hadith of the prophet talks
about standing up to oppression at least
hitting things in your heart joining
good and i would say very generally
enjoying good and forbid evil but for
that you even need to know what those
are to begin with go back to islam but
many things you could look the process
on him he was very brave he was very
emotionally intelligent he was very
soft-hearted when he needed to breathe
and he was even harsh when he needed to
be but i think overall having that
emotional intelligence to be able to
know what you need and when you need it
to know that you don't speak to a woman
the way you speak to a man you could
yell at a man and he'll be motivated
you'll yell at a woman she won't talk to
you for a month you know so
here's the thing bro i got a question
for you yeah you said enjoying good and
forbidding evil is something that we
should do to find that balance
that's not something so easy to do
nowadays right and if you're someone
who's a pacifist and and i want to you
know touch on this point a little bit
when i refer to being a good man but
you're not good at being a man i'm
generally talking about the people that
are kind of acting like ostriches you
know they put their head on the ground
and they act like the world's actually
not coming to an end soon we're not
actually in a recession
it's actually we don't have an
islamophobia problem everything seems
good everything's actually safe because
if i'm not looking at it directly
i can just forget about it and i'm
living in my in my matrix and my fairy
tale these are the men i'm talking about
you know
to enjoying good and forbid evil takes a
relative amount of discipline
disagreeableness
you know tendency to go against the
grain look at the prophet saw bro look
at the seed of his life
he flipped all of saudi arabia upside
down bro at the time like he went
against every status quo possible that's
not being uh a nice guy per se that's
that's standing up for truth and and
while he was kind and he had other ben
that's very important right but he
didn't put the needs of everyone else in
society over the needs of allah and the
desires of allah and
what allah wants for us
you know so i think it's very important
to find that balance and just like was
saying what are the things that you know
we should talk about the base you know i
want to add to some of the points that
brother ramirez did mashallah um number
one bravery we look at the quran we look
at khalid rahim allah or
and he he encompassed that he was known
as the sword of allah right so bravery
is definitely one
and we can talk about this in a little
bit or another episode uh number two
we need to have
the ability to be fair and just right
what does this mean bro you know can can
we can we truly love all of our wives
the same
can we truly be all fair and all just
you know that's that's not up to me but
can we strive for that of course right
so being fair meaning we don't leave
anyone oppressed we treat all of our
children equally we treat all of our
women folk equally in terms of wives we
don't take money from the orphans bro
one of the major sins you know take
taking money from those who are already
broke or or impoverished and stuff like
that so you're just being fair bro
number three you respect the vessel and
body that allah has given you
this is not our body you know so we
should do what we can with it we should
work out we should be healthy we should
eat good food be clean
number four bro
you want to talk about that a little bit
jealousy protective jealousy but what
else what does this even mean
because because
the the mob they're going to hear us and
they're going to think oh my god you
guys are so controlling you guys are
overprotective
so how do you break the zone
well i mean
i don't think
i don't think i'm the right person to
say this rami
why not man
you have a hero
yeah yeah what does it mean to be a
because i'm i'm still new i'm still new
and i don't want to
like give an altered
message
all right that's fair i respect
is protectiveness over your women
generally right you get married you have
mother you have sisters right so on and
so forth it's protectedness over them
it's that that feeling that men
naturally get and it is natural muslims
and non-muslims yes every single every
man male even
they'll have this deep down inside at
least at some point in their life even
if it's when they're young
where they'll see like you know
a man talking to their their mom or a
stranger or their sister and they'll be
like who the hell is this guy
why he's talking to my sister and he
walk over there just puffed out what's
your name yeah what's up is he bothering
you
that protectiveness that even if you
don't go and do that that you at least
feel that's rira and that is something
you need to act upon in islam you need
to have protectiveness over your wife
you need to encourage you to wear hijab
and to be covered and so on and so forth
and to avoid what honestly unfortunately
most women are doing nowadays and
unfortunately most men are allowing it
to happen nowadays
women going out flaunting themselves
doing whatever they're doing nowadays
unfortunately men are allowing this and
women are going to be like oh it's not a
man's choice it's not a man's choice but
it's a man's choice to
encourage or discourage it and at the
very least we can follow the quran
he tells us exactly what to do he says
advise them kindly if they don't listen
leave the bed and if they still don't
listen after that point where you're
taking your attention away from them
you're not even sleeping beside them in
the same bed then you can divorce
or at least signal that you're going to
divorce
[Laughter]
[Music]
rami was going to say if it doesn't work
at that point yo take out that miswak
boy and just
lay the oh all right it's not like that
no no brother's too hard like just like
zooming on this finger bro just just
like just a little bit bro
and and and the the tough of uh one of
the scholarly opinions i can't say
there's a majority it's not up to me i'm
not a messiah but it's that it's to
demonstrate your superiority and
physicality bro it's not to actually
cause physical harm and it's forbidden
bro the tough the majority of seed is
that we can't even and hit anyone you
know unjustly to cause permanent damage
or anything like that serious damage or
anything but
why why is this a step bro because we
understand that as as men
we can't enforce
under most circumstances but we have to
remind we have to encourage just like
brother amy said we have to enjoy and
good and forbid evil and there's a way
to do it bro there's context and and
everything is a case-by-case basis bro
but simply put bro
is this protective jealousy that
everyone feels that you feel deep down
and you want to express this of course
but this satanic world that we live in
wants to neuter this feeling that we
have
and use shaming tactics such as you know
barbaric controlling misogynist
oppressive listen i don't give a crap
about what these shaming tactics mean
and how they want to use it long story
short i care about what allah wants for
me and from me and it's to be hayub
um
lots of references from the quran and
sunnah that allah himself is jealous
of of of his creation bro and that's why
we have a specific standard that we must
adhere to a specific dress code a
specific way of life specific islamic
traditions farah all that
right so long story short if you're a
man and you don't have khrira what are
you doing right this is also one of the
things what's this number three number
four bro what are we on
i'll give him one more why not you know
number four this was number four i don't
remember number five last one no no
specific order and just like rami said
there's probably so many we miss bro
that's why we have a whole podcast we
don't have one episode
number five one of the most important
things is
your salah
your obligation to allah
how are you going to be expected to be a
good like we were literally talking
about this bro subhanallah before the
podcast right it was time for salah
right we kind of like forgot you know it
was margaret of time but we didn't miss
margaret or anything like that but it
was time to record and i was like bro
let's let's let's all pray maghrib you
know and we decided we're going to play
maghrib
just because of the risk that maybe we
might finish the episode and we might
have missed mughal
we might have still made maghrib i don't
know but what i do know is there's a
chance we might have not been able to
you know pray maghrib we might have
missed it so let's pray maghrib
finish it you know take our time with it
then record because at the end of the
day this is a a truth it's a covenant we
have with allah
you know we can't we can't say one thing
and then say something else
next time on dragon ball z like
romney by the way don't don't feel like
we were
not listening to what you're saying it's
just bro like
you were saying it and then
me and father we were on the same page
and we just looked at each other and
then fire went like this
yeah but um all right getting serious
here getting serious
so yeah so we have the quran
and then we have all the things that
fayette had mentioned
um don't even put those two things in
the same line bro
that's why i said
the quran and the left and right right
you have to think
very
simple here
right
what is most required of you where you
are
right now like maybe
maybe you are not married
right maybe you are still
um living in your house with your
parents
your family
um you don't really have any plans of
getting married or anything like that
what's most required of you
right now
what can you best do in this situation
to not only be a good man but be the
best man that you can possibly be right
like maybe
what you could do is
start learning how to make some money
you know you can get a job and you can
start learning how to make even more
money because if you only get a job and
you're only content with just having a
job whether you're going to be stuck
there you're going to be stuck making
that money working for someone else you
got to learn how to make money
in order to make money
and that's pretty self-explanatory
that's a simple thing right
um but again you just look at your
situation and you look at like what you
need
best you know like let's say
for the example purpose you're about to
get married
right you're about to get married
what is required of you you need to be
able to provide
you need to be able to represent
protect
yes right you must be able to be willing
to put your own life on the line and
sacrifice your life so that your family
survives
this is an obligation upon you
you
[Music]
must be working on your relationship
with allah getting closer to allah
because what good is getting married
being able to provide for your girl
being able to defend your girl
by having no connection with allah
basically what's the point of being good
at being a man if you're not a good man
yeah that's what it is
as uh
allah said that if i disobey allah
i notice the effects of it in the
behavior of my wife
and the camel that i ride
or in my mouth in some other narrations
basically means that you get real-time
consequences when you're disobeying
allah what is disobedience to allah bro
what are some of the things that that is
disobedience to allah that people don't
even realize
i'll give you one not waking up for fajr
all right that's fair
there's two ways to disobey allah
there's not doing things he commands
that you do
and there's doing things he commands not
right for you not to do basically so
allah commands you to pray fajr you
don't pray fajr right that's a sin
that's sinful because you're not doing
something allah commanded you to
um and the other one obviously allah
says you know don't drink alcohol right
and then you drink alcohol that is a sin
as well especially when you know 100
it is sinful you're disobeying allah
but luckily or thankfully alhamdulillah
allah makes it very easy if we slip up
to come back
[Music]
tell my servants who have transgressed
against themselves do not despair on the
mercy of allah
indeed allah forgives all sins and it is
him or indeed he is the most forgiving
most merciful very simple you mess up
you disobey allah actually every single
human being does you just have to ask
for forgiveness and aim to do better and
this kind of ties into the point i
wanted to make
which is that i think the most one of
the most important things is the ability
and the willingness to get better and
change so bro well so many people are so
scared of change they can't even move
out of their their neighborhood bro
subhanallah you know so it's hard for
them to look themselves in the mirror
and be like you know what i kind of suck
i need to be better all right and listen
a lot of us do suck
sometimes we suck at something sometimes
you suck overall but the the most
important thing to do is recognize that
you suck and be better the biggest
problem you can have is not knowing that
you have a problem because then no
progress gets made say that one more
time bro the biggest problem you can
have is not knowing that you have a
problem
so
recognize the faults have the
willingness to change have the ability
to change which comes with practice and
the right efforts and look in the right
places and learning the right way which
brings me back to the quran and the son
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
guys just a quick little random thing
guys i want you guys to get your hands
up we're going to make some dua right
now let's go all of you
yeah allah please
allow
these four cameras that we have to still
be recording i mean and once this
episode is done and once we're done
speaking
please you know have this episode
recorded and not something that you know
the cameras are dead or didn't even
record
and inshallah accept everything we're
doing
because guys we don't know we don't know
we're just talking we're rambling we
might go there and it might even say
storage for
i don't know
but if everything goes according to plan
insha allah
this would be episode one i'm not saying
we're wrapping up yet but
first of many inshallah for the
foreseeable future you guys are gonna
get episodes every single friday um they
should be july first inshaallah but it
should be every single friday for the
next couple years maybe even decades bro
i don't know how long you know it's all
written
of allah um
but i wanted to you know close this on
on a beautiful point
that
before islam to after islam
how has your definition of just being a
good man changed we'll talk about being
good at being a man after but how was
your perception of that changed
joe i feel like
when uh matt walsh that's his name right
yeah when he was asking women like what
is a woman
i feel like you asked me like what is a
man
loki
a biological male
an adult an adult meal they're gonna
hate that bro they're gonna hate that
yeah well um
before islam
what i used to think
was like a proper man
was like
number one a dude who had money
number two a dude who was like diesel
like stacked
you know where you looked at him you're
like oh damn like oh this
myself uh like this guy well i wasn't
muslim so i wouldn't say masha allah but
um
stacked diesel
and then the third one
is that
he could pretty much get like any girl
that he wanted
isn't it crazy that all of these things
now look like they just make you good at
being a man
yeah or at least among some of the
things makes you good at being this idea
of what a man is
i'm not necessarily a good man yeah and
then now that i'm muslim
actually do you guys want to answer no
no i'm going bro i'm going yeah what
does a good man know i'll be your muslim
now that i'm muslim man a good man
is uh obviously a man who has
proper nia he has the proper intention
always right he's always trying to do
better he's always trying to take care
of the people that he's with and stuff
like that
um but a man like a proper man who's
good at being a man and he has this this
aspect of being a good man
is the one who embodies
these things who doesn't just have the
intention but he also embodies it you
know what i'm saying god bro i think you
summed it up perfectly bro i think this
whole episode we tried to like you know
ramble and come up with the perfect
thing but i think that's damn close bro
say that one more time not only do you
you know want good or have the intention
but what do you do you embody it you
embody it you have to have it and
i think we did answer in the very
beginning when we were talking about the
prophet so the law was
like
not only did he
you know
no no not delivered but
not only did he um
you know relay the message to us the
quran
but he embodied
it yeah wow so that was by definition
not only a good man but a man that was
damn good at being a man bro
[Music]
yeah because because being a good man
might just mean you know you got the
message you understand
but how many people can practically
apply it how many people can put their
skin in the game and and you know really
put it into practice that's what makes
you good at being a man yeah right so
smile i think that's that's wonderful
but on me bro i want to ask you now um
let's just say you know pre
there's no pre-islam but just earlier in
in the in the hell days the days of
ignorance versus now what's changing
your perception of just being a good man
i mean that's that's the funny thing man
i never had a perception of what a man
is i never had a definition i never
cared it was never a big thing to me you
know i what i even really differentiate
between a man someone who's a man or a
male who's a man and a male who's not a
man honestly
very i had very dif very little
differentiation between men and women in
general to be completely honest i didn't
see much of a difference i only i
honestly thought a good man is like what
you see on tv you know like he he gets
like a woman flowers and he's always
nice to her and he always agrees with
her and he the agreeable soft little you
know that kind of man
that's what i thought a man was when you
come to islam alhamdulillah you find
subhanallah
man there's so much to being a man you
can't really summarize it right it's
it's not really something you can
explain right it's something you have to
observe
right it's something you have to
experience right and i don't i don't
think you can really experience what
it's like to be a man so you have women
in your life
honestly i feel like that's when your
manhood comes out a lot like your sister
wants to go shopping you know give her
some money to go shopping you're now a
bit of a provider you know your sister
he wants to go out but you know you want
someone there to protect her you go out
with her you go and protect her now
you're physically protecting her as well
you know someone needs guidance someone
needs someone to kind of lead them you
take that roland now you're a leader as
well masha'allah and it comes honestly
i'd say from experience but it's not
until you can actually go out
and experience these things that you'll
know what a man is but if you want a
place to read about what a man was like
or
you know what a man is like and what the
characteristics are of a man or a man in
practical situations just look at the
process in him there's a sheikh i think
mikhail smith he has beautiful lectures
on the emotional intelligence of the
process he could see how soft and kind
and smart and wise he was with his wives
and what he would say and what he
wouldn't say and when he would speak
when he wouldn't say anything and just
walk away
he bro he took a break from all of his
wives from i think like a month or so
completely like just abstaining from all
of them
and he slept at a sahabi's house
you know how many men today would take
even five hours away from their
so i don't know wives real bro because
we look at the prophet sallam and and
and all of the prophets and all of the
sahaba
they had the perfect perfect perfect
balance of of
you know embodying the middle path
never in one extreme never another we
see a lot of you know
buddhist monks today you know going into
the mountains completely away from
civilization spirituality you know
that's all they're about but they lost
their connection with the dunya bro but
you look at too many people today in
this material world bro
breeding degeneracy just deep into dunya
bro they'll know how to make money and
mashallah maybe they're making 30 50k a
month
when's the last time they've been to the
majority you know maybe they
they're here you know sleeping with all
these girls but do they have a wife
you know maybe they're out here uh
having so much fame bro having like four
or five million followers
but maybe they're making stupid tweets
and just looking like a fool in public
shout out to kanye
but at the end of the day how many
people can say that they've lived a life
where they're grateful and cognizant
that allah has shown them
the blessings in being the middle path
and islam is a middle nation
do not be extreme in matters of faith
but also don't be too caught up in the
deception the dagger of the dunya
you know so
first and foremost it's a reminder to
myself but
in the last few months definitely years
but last few months especially after we
started the podcast i realized one thing
that
when you get too caught up in dunya
right it's a very slippery slope most of
us don't realize we're getting caught up
in dunya and when we get to kara
pandunya it's very easy to forget the
akhira
very easy to get too caught up in the in
the days of commerce and trade and
making money and you forget that you
missed
right but when you get too caught up in
in in which isn't a bad thing but two
caught up in that there you you know you
forget you're like remember the the
hadith of uh where the the three men
came to the prophet islam and they said
that you know i'm gonna pray uh all
night long or i'm gonna pray forever i'm
never gonna stop the other one said i'm
gonna continue fasting you know the
other one said i'm never gonna sleep
with my wife something like that right
and and the prophet saw mentioned you
know no
sleep with your wife when it's when it's
permissible
pray you know what what you're required
to but don't just pray 24 7 365 and and
and fast one essentially don't don't you
know fast like there's a there's a net
there's a necessary amount of
spirituality and
foreign away with this
this is not like
do or die and then all you have to spend
your time with is this you know be be
and don't take you know words out of my
mouth and i know people are going to be
here like oh if i had said we don't have
to pray that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying we definitely have to pray we
definitely have to do everything that
allah wants us to do
but what else are you doing with your
time in dunya
go to the gym eat clean
journal or spend time reflecting on the
blessings allah has given you
do something with your life have some
type of purpose have some type of either
a career and we don't all have to go to
school but if you can go to school if
you can't start a business
if you work at a job you know eventually
find a way to get financially free
inshallah we'll talk about some business
stuff coming up
um but essentially like how can you get
into a higher level of positioning in
the dunya
and simultaneously work on your own
islam
and use that positioning to inspire
other people to islam
i think this is kind of like the
foolproof plan and i don't know about
y'all but i'm sure you guys are on the
same page we're trying to do the same
thing yeah this the nia and by the way
famous is a necessary evil by the way
it's not something you know we want or
anything like that but with the
positioning with the influence we want
to keep our nia straight and guide other
people to islam
and continue to work on our own islam
right we're not going to use this fame
and let it get to our heads or anything
like that
i want to
correct you
but
with love
it's uh the
the one dude was saying that um
he was gonna pray all night all night
right and then i believe because the
prophet saws too yeah and then the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
um
i pray a part of the night and i sleep
part of the night
and then when you said to the guy that
said he's never gonna be
intimate with his wife
he said that he is intimate with his
wives
what was the other one that i'm uh i'm
gonna fast
oh yeah they wasn't gonna eat i'm never
gonna eat i don't know oh yeah they said
that sometimes he fast and sometimes he
doesn't fat sometimes he breaks it
sometimes he doesn't break right well
you always break it but you hear what
i'm saying yeah
yes
mashallah and and bro
you know
you correcting me or anything like that
the way that you did it is something
that a lot of gentlemen and maybe
sisters too but just muslims today need
to embody and understand
the way we give people advice and the
way we take it two very important things
in islam islam is the only religion
where a six-year-old can correct an imam
and the imam has to listen if it's valid
you know
um based on obviously from the prophet
sallam and and the rulings and all that
but when we look at people correcting us
right
just touch on this a little bit before
we end this how should we give nasiha
from what you've learned because being a
reaver bro
i want to say
barakallahu fukum bro but i also want to
say my condolences because i know how
some of the muslims be acting today and
this is a problem we need to talk about
this but how have you been given nasiha
in ways that it didn't really benefit
you
no names
no of course i wouldn't put anyone on
blast like that
um
then let's see how that works is no no
no no no no it doesn't work let's go on
it doesn't work yeah that doesn't work
at all that you've had
the one where
they're trying to tell me blatantly that
i'm wrong straight to my face also give
me an example
but if i give an example that's gonna be
give me an example
give me an example of a brother talking
to another brother it doesn't have to be
you make up a scenario
but it's obviously gonna be attributed
to
me why because i'm giving a scenario but
why don't you give a scenario of of
someone speaking to a sister
let's say a sister wearing the hijab
wrong
give an example there's baby hair
showing
baby is
yeah a little
oh like okay so if a guy comes cafe
[Laughter]
if a guy comes up to him he's like oh
you're a cafe
they're trying to say this stuff because
she's not covering completely maybe she
doesn't even know
yeah maybe she didn't right maybe she
didn't know or
maybe
just maybe
she's in a specific part in her journey
of coming to allah
and
basically learning the deen more and
more
like this is something that we don't
know allah knows best
so for
us to say that she is
basically far because she's not covering
her hair entirely
i think that would make us go far
because we're making you guys call it
right yeah making tech feel like like if
we were like if we know we know best
when we don't know anything we're
ignorant like we're kawage yeah
so it's like this guy
you know maybe this guy had the best
intention he had good intention bad
action
but exactly and because he had bad
action
the good intention is canceled out
because the bad action
could potentially make the sister stray
in fact she could uh be led astray
and basically follow islam less and less
to the point where she does
become
a catholic she does completely leave
islam
so the better way to have approached it
would be to
you know see where she's coming from
like see how her journey is going in
islam right
and then
if you know
you start asking her about the hijab
like how's the hijab going for her
and all this stuff and see where she's
at with that mentally emotionally
spiritual all this stuff then you can
have an understanding now you have
context
and that's what's missing with a lot of
people is the context we talked about
this but now you have the context when
you have the context you see ah
this is why she's wearing it like this
yeah you know or or maybe she was taught
that all you got to do is just cover up
the head exactly not here specifically
exactly you know what i mean yeah and if
you look at the um hadith i think of um
where he said something along the lines
of if you see alcohol dripping from the
beard of your brother assume someone
spilled it on him
right you're supposed to and there's
another hadith that says you're supposed
to make x amount of excuses for your
brother or something like that you're
supposed to excuse your brother right
and same thing obviously same thing with
sisters so if you see that
excuse her all right maybe she doesn't
know it's not tight enough maybe she
doesn't know that she's supposed to wear
it like that
and uh one little tip and this kind of
falls into emotional intelligence that i
find works honestly all the time start
off with a compliment someone like him
sister masha allah you know you have may
allah reward you for your hijab i can
only imagine how difficult it would be
may i
yeah you know there's there's one thing
my sheikh taught me and i want to you
know let you know about it because i i
didn't know about it allah when he says
when he talks about hijab and so and so
in the quran he uses this specific word
all right i actually forget the word
allah talks about um
there's jilbab and there is
what's the uh
thank you
yes
if you look at the original arab like
the dictionaries and that we use when we
kind of look at how they use these words
and so on and so forth is something that
is typed wrapped around the head covers
everything and the same piece of cloth
drapes down and goes over the chest you
know so actually wearing a turban
doesn't cause hijab i didn't even know
that i just learned that i wanted to
share that with you because i see you're
wearing the turbine so you're wearing
the stat the other and i thought it'd be
helpful to you know
walk away that's all you really need
done
how can she hate you with that bro how
can she she look back at it and then be
like you know what i'm never going to
win a job if you came at it with that
type of gentleness humility
yeah worst case scenario sorry one
second worst case scenario only thing
that's going to come out of her if she
doesn't uh one or two things either
her ignorance will show and she will
accept it right and be like you know
what i didn't know that at least at
least she'll say let me look into it let
me ask a teacher let me whatever you
know that's fair
or her arrogance will come out you know
no no no that's not what hijab is no i
don't i don't care him or this whatever
that's not what hijab is look at how
people are wearing it nowadays hijab is
just so i just need to cover my head
that's that's all hijab is you know
arrogance right there um and i think in
that case
you could see she's pushing herself away
and it wasn't really your fault
this is where i i really think
is very important for us to
develop a common ground with the person
and um get to see where they're coming
from meet them where they're at
like hamza zois has said you meet the
person over there you don't meet them
where you think they're at
and um it's very it's very strong
because i mean when you do this
um it basically
it disarms the ego
you know like
even the way that you're saying is
proper right but if
the person's really only gonna like step
down and accept it if they've already
kind of been working on themselves and
they've already been at that point where
they they've been putting their ego down
yeah right like
if you guys grow fired come on like you
you know me
you know me before islam like if you
would have came to me trying to say
something that even though i was doing
self-improvement
my ego was sold through the roof that
the moment you said something bro like i
was like
on the offensive
and i was basically trying to shut down
anything that was being said to me but
it's cause you knew you're worth baby
girl
listen i don't know about that but what
i'm saying
is that um the ego nothing was nothing
nothing would get through to you bro
unless you were open to it yeah and
mashallah now you you're very open to it
and i see the change that islam has
brought through to you
and not just him bro all of us and the
other guys all but that means
it shows how much you don't know
anytime someone checks you or corrects
you and you could take it as an attack
or you could take it as you know a
lesson and something to introspect and
reflect on
now we already talked about how we
should give nasiha and what types of
messiah doesn't work or don't work right
but one thing i wanted to end on was
when it comes to ncr period right
if you want to remind other people
guide them give them some type of advice
right
a lot of people and narami touched on
this many times but i do want to end on
this point one more time a lot of people
have this preconceived notion this false
notion that i'm not ready to give lucia
bro
i'm here doing xyz behind closed doors
i'm i'm sitting myself
you know who am i to give and i see her
i'm worried about myself
there's um this thing that i saw we
talked about this where we were going to
get your food
last week
where it's like even if you are
[Music]
committing the sin
yourself and you see someone doing the
same thing that you're doing that's the
sin
you should still give them nasiha
because
it's like the prophet sallallahu alaihi
who said allah
you follow a bad deed with a good deed
right so even though you're sinning
and you know like this person's doing
the exact same thing that you're doing
like you can potentially
allah knows best but you can potentially
um erase that yeah and unlock and erase
all of your good deeds and replace them
with or bad deeds and then replace them
with good things
that's [ __ ]
now i got a question for you what do you
have to say about all these people that
are only too concerned about giving
other people nasiha and don't even look
in the mirror and look at themselves oh
man that's
they're a whole other breed bro that's
not something else found allah people
are focused on giving what they would
call messiah to other people and can't
look at themselves
subhanallah um
i wouldn't even call it really nasia at
that point they can mask it as that but
honestly it i think it's uh i think it's
a facade i think people have an
arrogance issue and i think people
i don't know what to call it to be
honest but obviously people that people
want some kind of control some kind of
you know telling people what to do some
kind of command over people some kind of
honestly self-righteousness yeah and
want to see themselves as being above
others and so on and so forth
and um
i would say these these people are kind
of tired of the same people that
just kind of attack people online you
know people tell on all the time oh
cover up your tattoos you know
subhanallah
you know i cover them up i love you
forgiving them guys
what are you trying to do bro and we
know about riya and showing off and how
much of a sin it is bro for the sake of
you know first person answered
a hadith of the quran someone who
memorized the quran
will be the first person to enter
jahannam
because the niyyah the reason behind him
doing it was just to kind of show off to
the people
yeah think about that bro we're not even
memorizers of the quran bro
the first person to enter jahanam is
going to be someone who remembers the
quran just to show off to people
not because they actually wanted to put
into practice guide others enjoying good
for everybody evil but just show off
kind of show everyone you know i'm
better you're not yo uh cover your hair
yo cover your tattoos yo do this you'll
do that
and then they go home and and do
stuff for allah god knows only
yeah and i want to touch on that point
because you guys talked about earlier
the whole like intention and action all
that stuff
if you have
good intention right
bad action
you're not rewarded i don't think you're
sin you're you're sinful necessarily
allah adam but you're not given a reward
if you have
um a good action with a bad intention
you might actually be sinful
just like you mentioned you might
actually be sinful if you have a bad
intention
and a a good action because obviously
you know fasting and praying and giving
in charity and reciting quran these are
beautiful actions but when you do it for
the sake of what you mentioned showing
off to the people so they can look at
you like oh what an amazing person you
know
i remember hearing a funny story once uh
guy was praying in the masjid and uh
he was in sujud for so long and two
people were talking about him and one
guy was like um it's the guy's still
praying the guy's still praying right
and when two guys are talking about him
say oh my this guy's always praying he's
always in the masjid he went to jude for
so long and the guy while he's praying
is like you should see my fasting or
something like that you know
but
it's a very scary thing intentions are
one of those things or if you don't have
it right it's the foundation right you
don't have a right everything else is
going to be completely messed up i want
to say
two more things insha'allah
if i can remember the first one start
with the second one allah
[Music]
basically people who are trying to get
the prophet saws to pray in their
masajid in their houses of worship
places of worship but it was created and
founded upon something that was i think
shirk or koforo something like that but
they really wanted to get the prophet
pray here maybe probably for bad reasons
right
and allah he made this honestly scary
analogy he basically said and i'm going
to paraphrase a little bit because i
don't remember exactly but he's like
which is better
the the place that was created you know
the house of allah was created for the
sake of allah for the purpose of allah
it was started for allah
or and this is the comparison or
a house that was created on the edge of
a crumbling building or a crumbling
cliff right a building that was created
on the edge of a crumbling cliff that
fell over into hellfire
all what was the difference the
intention in starting it
and the second thing or the first thing
i want to mention i remember now the
hadith i think it was um
who narrated it
that says actions are by their
intentions
and then this became kind of a practice
for the um other people who collected
you know hadith compilation so on so
forth to put this first
the actions are by their intentions
very scary man i want to touch on these
actions about its intentions subhanallah
we all know the story about the
uh i forgot which which uh scholar of
our time
but it was basically there was this this
guy who basically prayed you know on
time on point at least you know all
other variables aside for about seven
years 70 years
and then he i believe committed zinna
for about one week you know what i'm
talking about yeah and uh
i believe he was
uh
in in terms of you know
in on the scales
the one week of of doing zina
superseded and exceeded the 70 years of
ibadah superseded that and if i was to
ask you brother anha before we give him
away uh give the answer away not give
him away what do you think why do you
think that is why do you think one week
of zena
exceeded seven years of worship
because it's showing clear disobedience
to allah
i thought that too
or or how much of a major synergist no
why it's because for the 70 years he
wasn't even praying properly
he didn't know his religion
he didn't understand how to pray
properly bro
so subhanallah knowing your religion
good action and good intention all comes
from seeking knowledge and and being
informed
you know
and then the other story can be given
and we should definitely wrap up i think
we've been going far too long yeah so
and we don't even know if it was
recording guys so the fact that i kept
looking over there to make sure like yo
is this the mics muted or what
it's still going to audience
but the last thing i want to say it also
goes back to the um
the story of the
i was adjusting my phone bro my bad yeah
yeah
the story of
barcessa
the story of the the guy who
had
um basically like
he ended the lives of many people 99
1999 and then when he had gone to
the um
the pastor the sheikh all the pastors at
first oh
and then he asked he's like oh i've done
this like
well god forgive me and then the pastor
was like no like
god's not gonna forgive you so then he
ended up
like finishing him off
and then
[Laughter]
[Music]
listen he ended up finishing him off
just say finishing him
why do you have to say off
finish again
he ended up bringing him you're finished
you're finished you're finished with the
algae you're finished
damn
he's trying to
end him
finish him off
and
then he goes to a shaykh and he has to
shake the same question
and the shaykh says yes but you need to
leave
this area this vicinity right away and
so he starts he starts going off
and
stuck for a
what is this listen i'm trying to be
serious with you i'm trying to be
serious bro you can't be serious
mommy didn't have his ice cap bro we're
going to get him an extra big ice cava
mute yourself i'm you yourself right now
yeah he didn't unmute it bro he's still
laughing no no no okay i'm unmuted
listen this is why we should have gotten
the popcorn before recording
and the ice cap
but finishing the story
a lot of finishing today
finishing the story
um the sheikh said he needs to get out
of here
so he was based
he was
he started leaving
right he started leaving
and he died
before reaching the destination
you all right romey i'm good
he been when he died
the angels were recording everything and
uh allah basically made the distance
between
the uh place he was going to and the
place he was leaving
uh shorter can i jump in here
what actually happened
but he's doing good though
when he when he died right he was
traveling he died both the angels of
mercy and the angels of punishment came
both of them
and they're basically i don't want to
say arguing because i don't know exactly
but they're discussing who's going to
take him the angels of mercy the angels
of wrath obviously huge difference right
and then allah said to measure the
distance between where he is now the
place he was going to right and where he
is now in the place he was coming from
if he's closer to the place he he left
right that he left from then the angels
of irath would take him right he'd be
punished essentially if he was closer to
the place he was going to then the
angels of mercy would take him new life
new destination
fresh clean
and then what happened
allah show in the distance subhanallah
yeah you was close to the destination
yeah so it shows that like
good intention followed with
the good action yes
changes everything yeah yeah 100 and
just one more note i want to add they
measured it once and he was closer to
the place he left which means he was
going to be punished and then allah in
the distance from the place he was at in
the place he was going to find allah
just because of his intention of going
and you know seeking forgiveness and
starting a new life subhanallah
and subhanallah is crazy that what we
were saying
that up a proper man
is a man who not only has the intention
but embodies
these intentions
and just think about this
this guy in this story
right he had the intention and he was
embodying that intention he was going
seeking refuge seeking forgiveness
right
and like that's i'm just saying man like
islam like islam just shows us
how to be proper men how to be good men
how to be good at being man
and with that being said i think
we have concluded this episode yeah if
you guys liked it please smash this like
button share with echuan with the
shabbat and stay tuned for episodes
coming up in sha allah a lot of stuff
we're going to be talking about
preparing for nikah you know being a man
of high value in the light of quran and
sunnah
advice for sisters as well you know
getting married
uh
why are you guys always telling my
intimacy why this whole thing my
intimacy i don't mean bro say what we
said in the intimacy episodes what is
the importance of muslims learning about
intimacy real quick man uh
y'all like game to be honest i mean you
better hear first
you're like game no but seriously i mean
if you
listen intimacy is everything in a
relationship people don't like to talk
about it it's honestly it's everything
if if a couple and this actually what
brother gabriel said if a couple is um
you know alhamdulillah you know
and they have the same belief the same
al-qaeda and their their intimacy is on
point right everything else would be
fine
and you know what they know quickly
they did i think it was a study or one
thing that's common amongst um you know
couples who are getting divorced or
divorcing or going through therapy going
through a rough patch none of them are
intimate none of them are intimate and
well some people some therapists they
recommend that you know just be intimate
again just start up again and honestly
in some cases at least it fixes it fixes
a big big big portion of it it's just
one of those things and also found allah
it makes a man feel like a man
and the woman feels like a woman and
they're right bro
yeah it's a it's the glue that holds
relationships and marriages together
right so with that being said guys if
you made it this far comment down below
hashtag
man
just so we know who actually made it to
the end hashtag mansplaining 89 of
people already tuned up
within like the first two minutes
no i'm just playing not two minutes but
that would be pretty bad analytics maybe
20 minutes or so but for the for the
gang that made it this far insha'allah
comment down below hashtag man
uh let us know what you guys think or
thought of this first episode insha
allah
um
we are not going to be filming this
again and this actually went through
because we don't know well you guys we
we actually don't know perhaps we might
look at the cameras and the audio it
actually didn't record and then we're
going to be back to square one we might
leave youtube who knows
but maybe allah has willed it for it to
work out insha'allah
for a reason
and we thank you all for your support
insha allah this studio was all possible
because of the works of you guys and the
effort good intention and action of you
guys you know so may allah bless you for
that and give you even more reward than
us
and aside from that bro rami
what you got and with that being said
allah
bro just imagine he did that and like
sliced the sure sm7b in half
i had spatial awareness
yes special winners guys he's uh he's a
fighter
yeah bro uh y'all let's get some popcorn